Lynden ass in the first 30 seconds of
someone meeting you
what do you reveal about yourself Linda
this is a great question and I'm gonna
give you a great I'm declaring a great
answer alert I can probably get somebody
to consume something from me within the
first 13 seconds let alone 30 seconds
because it's not what I'm gonna say it's
how I feel see words are great but
energy is a whole different game and I
win on that game right and so within the
first 30 seconds I'm gonna establish and
have always established for my entire
life
from first grade first 30 seconds into
any business meeting to when I'm in a
big off site when everybody goes around
the room and says I'm Stefan I work at
vaynermedia but then I do my I'm Gary
I'm a Jets fan like I within 30 seconds
set the tone vibe wise if I don't get to
say something which is rare for me
enough to say something within the first
30 seconds I establish that I'm
different
yeah I'm different don't forget to
subscribe to my youtube channel
you